Okay. So guys, welcome to the call officially. I had a few announcements a second ago, but
welcome to the actual call. We got Porter on the call today. I know you guys have probably
seen him quite a bit lately and that's because he's been having a lot of success and also
because when somebody, you know, gets on these lives and is posting in the group, it forces
them to also have success. So it's a win-win situation. But what I want to talk about today
and why I wanted to bring Porter on is because I want to talk about Porter's path to 10K a month
and also remind you guys that this is while he's been taking over the family farm. And also I
didn't mention this because it would have made the title too long, but also while they just had their
first child, was it back in October, Porter? Yeah, October. October what? October 4th.
October 4th. So for the last two, let's see, October, November, December. So the past three
and a half months, Porter's also, you know, had the stress, obviously the excitement, but the stress
and the non-sleeping and the emotional wife and all that kind of stuff that comes with having a
child. So for those of you that are like, I'm too busy. I've got a ton of stuff going on. We are
all too busy. We all got a bunch of stuff going on. And I want to show you guys that even despite
that, that you can, you can go and get 10K. You can go and everybody should expect to be at 10K.
Okay. That's just the, that should be just the expectation, not to get your first deal, not to
get your second deal, but to get to 10K. And then from 10K, you can move up from there, but there's
no reason why you can't go and carve out a couple of deals. Porter, of your 10K, how many
deals is that? Is that 10 deals? Is it eight deals? Is it 12 deals? How many, how many business owners
are you working with or how many websites is the 10K spread amongst? I want to say it's seven
clients and eight websites. Beautiful. So one of your sites, one of your clients, you double dip,
got a two for one, the old two for, and then the rest of them are just a little bit over a thousand
a month. Yeah. Basically. Okay. Amazing. So Porter, when did you, so I've got, I've got a list of nine
questions that I want to ask you. I don't want to hog all of it with, with my questions. I want you
guys to be able to ask questions. I also want to let everybody know upfront that I know because
Porter's my brother, it's probably easy to be, to think that I've helped him with a deal. It's
probably easy to think that I jumped on a call with him to close a business owner, that I referred
him a business owner. Porter, between you and God, have I ever jumped on a sales call? No, not one.
Have I ever given you a client? No, not one. None. Have I ever, do, have I, do I even,
when's the last time you and I even talked on the phone? I don't even remember actually. Yeah. Yeah,
it's been a minute. Now, obviously, if I see Porter, you know, family gatherings,
dinners, stuff like that, and he asked a question, I'm going to answer. But if you guys, for one
second, think he's getting private coaching to get to 10K, he is a student like anyone else in
this group. Okay. Just so everybody knows. In fact, sometimes he probably gets less than anyone else
because I don't want it to seem like that. So I want to just set the record straight. Porter has
done this completely on his own, watching the training, asking questions. I've of course,
answered a few of his questions, but it's not like I just answer. He called me every five seconds.
So let's get into these questions. But I want you guys all to know that if you have questions for
Porter, I want you to be able to ask them. And let's just talk about his path to 10K, how he
did it, raw facts. I will let you guys know he almost hit it. Then he dropped back. Then he
almost got there. Then he lost three deals. It was quite a thing. So Porter, my first question
I have for you, dude, is what took you so long to get to 10K, bro?
I think that that's the, that's the golden question.
So hold on. Let's, let's, let's be completely honest. So you, I, I tried to get Porter to do this
years ago, like, yeah, whatever. And I was like, Porter, you should jump in. You check this out.
I'm making money, whatever. And I think in the beginning it was interesting, but you didn't
do anything. So when did you officially start, like actually went through the training?
So that was, I want to say that was like two, two years ago that I actually went,
went through everything. Like two years ago or last two and a half years.
It was November of, yeah, November of 22 years ago. 22. So just over two years ago.
Yes. So just over two years ago, that's when I got my first deal. So that was right when I got
married. So like, I was like, okay, I got to make some money here. Cause I'm not making enough from
just doing the farm. And so I got the one deal and I was so like excited. Like I remember you get your
first deal. And I just was like, I was like, this is crazy that I got this deal. So I really went
all in at that point, but I still had some, like, I was still nervous because I didn't quite
understand like how emotional it was like to lose a client. And so like, I went to this phase
where I went balls to the wall for like three or four months until farming season. And I almost
got to 10 K within that short amount of time, I got to like 9,000 or something. And I just didn't
know how to keep a client. I didn't know that they needed to be closing jobs. I just thought,
Hey, I'm providing the elites. They're not closing the jobs. And I still was like, I was losing
clients pretty fast. I lost, I lost four clients in two weeks. I was, I was devastated
because all my income was gone. So I remember Thanksgiving 2022, our whole family, we went to
Scottsdale and in Arizona. And I remember you and I did a live there. And I think even by that time,
you had already landed a couple deals because I wouldn't have brought you on live if you hadn't.
So you had already gotten some momentum and then you really, really did well. And I remember what
ended up happening is it was right before I came to Africa, 2023, you were getting really close to
10 K. You were like around nine. Was it nine or 87? Like you were close, right? Yeah, it was really
close. And then you lost four deals in two weeks. What month was that? That was in, it was right
before I started farming. So it would have been like March, March, April. Okay, great. So how'd
you lose four deals in two weeks? What did you learn? How did you lose them? What did you learn?
How can people avoid that? And by the way, this happens. And, you know, I was talking to Drew
yesterday. We were laughing about it. Like we call it the December slaughter, right? If you're not
prepared, if you don't have contracts in place, you don't have business owners that are happy,
if you've sat and rested on your laurels, you can really get smoked. I got hit hard for two
December's in a row. And I said, never, ever, ever again. And thank goodness it hasn't happened
like that again. But yours didn't happen in December. So how did you lose four clients in
two weeks? Did you send them anthrax in the mail, dude? I mean, how do you, that's impressive.
I don't even know. So one of them, it was the craziest thing. One guy just like, he stopped
paying me. And so I reached out to him. He blocked my number on like everything. Like couldn't find
him on social media. Just completely just off the grid. Yep. The next guy, I don't even know. He
just stopped, he stopped paying like one of his charge card. And I was kind of, it was kind of
my fault. I think I kind of was being like, well, I charged his card, but it declined.
Okay. And then you said he had a charge card. I was like, well, that's your sign, dude. You may
as well take it. No, well, yeah. Well, it was just weird, like the whole situation. So he's like,
hey, charge this card this week, charge this card next week. And then I charged the wrong
card one week and he was like, Hey, I told you how to charge it. I'm like, dude, I need a card
that I can just leave on file. Anyways, it didn't work out. And then I, one of the cards declined
and I was kind of like, dude, I need some payment or like, I gotta move on. Cause he wasn't responding
to me. Anyways, we kind of left on a bad note and anyways, lost that client. So a lot of them were
the fact that they weren't making money though. What I didn't realize was that I have to supply
the leads, but I also have to make sure that they kind of know what they're doing and how to handle
these leads because if they don't make money, they're going to drop me. And that's exactly
what a lot of them did. They were getting plenty of leads, but they were answering the phone call
wrong. They were maybe just not as bubbly on the phone with these customers and they just weren't
closing a percentage that would allow them to keep doing what we're doing together. So
what I've learned is even through this winter is just like, you got to start doing more weekly
contact monthly con on a zoom call. Like just always be checking in on them. And it's funny
that the clients that I want, the clients that are easy to deal with, I never talk to them.
Like it's weird because you think you need to have this like tab on them all the time, but it's the
ones that are like, so they almost get annoyed for me reaching out. Those are the ones that you want
to work with. Yeah. I've said that a handful of times for those of you that have been in this
group from the beginning, if a client does not make money, they will cancel. I don't care how
many leads you're giving them. I don't care how good the leads are. I don't care how closeable
those leads are. I don't care how much they should have closed those leads. At the end of the day,
if a client, if a business owner does not make money, they will cancel, whether it's today,
whether it's next month, whether it's next year, they will cancel it. And unfortunately,
it's not your fault, but it is your business. So it's not your fault that they're not closing,
but you do need to make it your business that they close deals if you want to retain the client.
And so some of us, we get these clients where everything works out. We send them a decent
amount of leads. They're good at closing. It's so easy. We're like, why can't we find more
clients like them? But what you're not realizing is that because they're making money,
it's eliminating 99% of the problems and the issues and the customer service stuff and the
touch ins. And guys, when a client's making money, most of the problems go away. I heard
this quote by Grant Cardone years ago. He said, if you want to keep a client for life, make them
money. If you want to keep a client for money for life, make them money. And I deal with the same
thing in this group, right? Same training that Porter used to get to 10K. I have somebody who
comes in, doesn't do anything, makes no money. And they want to blame me. They want to talk badly
about me. They want to blame the program and it doesn't work and this and that. And it's like,
dude, this is the exact same, literally the exact same training that this person, Ryan Dalton's at
$87,000 a month. And this person's complaining that my stuff doesn't work. How does that work?
Well, this person didn't make money. And unfortunately, it's not my fault,
but it is my business. And so that's one of the reasons why with this new 3.0 training,
which by the way, will be out before the end of Q1 for anyone that's going to ask,
my focus is on how I can hold people's hand to that first deal and make it my business, because
that's just the fact of the matter is they are. And in this case, obviously it's not like you
can cancel because it's not a recurring payment, but you can not give me a good review or not
recommend me to people, which is the same as canceling with a business owner. So number one,
guys, is you do need to make it your business. Business owners have to be making money.
We all have these business owners where they just, you talk to them on the phone.
It doesn't seem quite right. You're like, dude, that guy's never going to close a deal.
They have a scattered operation and we're like, well, let me just close the deal so I can post
it in the group. And we've all, the reporter, you've closed some of these deals, right?
That you're like, I'm just going to get the deal. No upfront, it feels good, but long term,
it's not the move, man. Now you just locked your area up for six months and that's only,
it's only going to last two months or three months or six months in one day.
And you're going to be back to the drawing board. And so sometimes as you, as you
mature in business, you start to realize that just because you, this is a line that I really like is
just because you can take money or just because there is money on the table, doesn't mean you
should take it, right? Not all money is equal. Not all money is good. Yes, it spends the same,
but there's money that comes with a lot more hassle and a lot more headache and a lot more pain.
It's not worth it. And so that's number one. Number two, really quick is I was talking to
Drew about this because he had his December, he had a few clients come in and he was like,
he had a few clients canceled as well. And guys, what you need to understand is that business,
what's this business specifically, what you're, what a million dollar a year company looks like
is it looks like a bunch of clients that have like been with you from years back.
So I'll give you an example. In 2020, sorry, in 2019, we signed a client. That was my first flat
fee deal ever. Right. That client was a great client. That person was low maintenance and they
ended up staying with me up until like last year. And then they ended up doing their own website,
whatever, whatever, whatever. Okay. But then in 2020, we went and signed all these new clients
because that's when we scaled up to six figures a month. And of those, I don't even know exactly
how many clients, but let's say there was, you know, 60 clients that made up a hundred thousand
a month, or let's say there was 50. I know there was more than that because obviously
they weren't all 2000 a month, but let's just make it, or let's say there was a hundred,
just to make easy math out of those, let's say a hundred clients. The next two years later,
so that was 2020, let's say by 2022 of that original hundred clients that made up my
million dollar a year company, there's probably, there probably was only 25 or 30 of those clients
that were still with me two years later. And what I had to do in year 23, in 2021 and 2022
is I was going and finding tenants or clients that were good fits, right?
Imagine you had a hundred homes, you had to get all of them rented out. You're not going to go
find a hundred amazing tenants that pay their bills on time, that have good credit score,
that are going to keep the house clean, that aren't going to let their dogs pee all over the place,
that aren't going to have sound and parties on Friday nights.
What's going to happen is you're going to go and get a hundred of these houses filled
and 25 of those are going to be the amazing clients that are going to be with you for the
next 10 years. And guess what you're going to have to do with the next 75? You're going to have to go
and you're going to have to go and replace all of those people with the next batch.
And then maybe of those, another 30 stick. And now you've got 50, 55,
really solid clients. Those 10 year, 15 year, they don't even want to buy a house.
They're super happy to pay you rent as long as you treat them good.
And what happens is over the years, guys, you start to build up this base of clients brick by brick
of very, very low maintenance clients that once you get to where I'm in, I've legitimately been
doing this seriously since end of 2019, beginning of 2020. So now I'm four years, five years into
this. Now I finally have those clients where you guys hear me talking about, yeah, I haven't talked
to that client in two years personally. Yeah. Francesca reached out because his wife got a
surgery. But other than that, we haven't talked to him. So just so you guys understand when you
lose clients, it is part of the game. Think about it when you get tenants. Yeah, they needed a
place to stay, but you're not going to go pick a hundred good tenants right out the gate.
And so that is just the nature of this business. There's going to be turnover,
but understand as you grow, take good care of the ones of all of them, of course, but especially
at the ones that are low maintenance, those are going to be your lifers. Those are going to be
the people like I literally have clients still from 2020. Four years later, it paid me a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars a month in my Stripe account, and they require nothing from me. The
only thing they want to do is they want to talk on the phone. How can we expand? You guys know
my Bentonville concrete project. I always talk about that guy's name is Brooks 2020. We signed
the deal. He has never canceled, and he messaged us like twice this year. He's like,
let's get on a Zoom. Let's see how we can expand. And he's like, well, I need to wait because of
this. So that's it, guys. That's the type of clients that you want. That's what's going to
happen. So Porter, amazing job for setting the record of losing the most clients in two weeks.
But lesson learned is that, like you said, your clients have to make money,
your clients have to make money, and sometimes the money that's on the table isn't the money
that you should take. Okay. So next thing I want to ask you, you started really hot,
right? You started, let's call it October, November. You landed a bunch of deals,
almost got to 10K, and then you took your foot off the gas. Now, I know part of that was because you
had to go full time and with the farming and stuff like that. But what happened there? I mean, I
assume from the outside looking in, you kind of got the wind knocked out of you, kind of got a
little bit demotivated when you lost four clients, or was it mainly strictly to do with just being
distracted by the other, by taking over the farm? No, I think it has everything to do with I lost
four clients. I think being busy was an excuse, but I lost four clients. And it was like, I went
from making 9,000 to making like 3,000. And it kind of was like, it scared me a little bit. And I was
like, I got to hold on to these two clients. So I was almost like, what do I got to do to make sure
they're closing jobs so I don't make the same mistake? But what I didn't realize is like,
that's normal. And it's like, when you scale at a rapid pace, not all those people, like you said,
are going to be solid. So you just kind of have to keep the good ones and be okay with losing some
of these bad ones. But it was all a mentality of like, I wanted to get to 10K. And it was like,
that number was so big to me, like, because I wasn't, I mean, as far as like relevance with
money and like knowing how much a 10,000 is a lot of money, but like, there's more out there,
and I should expect more than that. I just was so afraid to like, hit that, you know what I'm
saying? I don't even know why it was like a mental roadblock. And then finally, I set a goal to hit
20,000, then I hit 10,000. And then I'm like, I just need to keep shooting my goals higher,
so that the goal that I'm going to hit is seems less than what I'm actually shooting for. Like,
it was just a mental thing. A lot of this is just mental. Like, if you can get over, you know,
spending the money, running the ads, being willing to make mistakes or lose clients,
and not take this so emotional, just say, Hey, this is just business. You're so much better off,
you know, I just was, I lost a trip when I was on a like, you lose a client while you're on like a
trip, or you're not around. And it makes you like, feel like you're, you're crappy, or you've done
something wrong. But it's in reality, it's like, it's probably just the client that you picked. And
it was just a bad time. So so you went down from almost 10k to two clients, right? Yeah. And are
those two clients that you went down to still with you? Yeah, I still have them. Go figure,
right? Just what I was saying, those two clients, if you treat them decently, or good, or heaven
forbid, you treat them really good, those clients will probably be with you for the next five, six,
seven, 10 years. So that's what I'm saying. He went out of let's say, when he got to nine and a
half, he probably had seven clients, he lost five, right? The two 20% of his clients, or whatever
that number is, it's less than that. He kept two clients. That too, is his base that those clients
are lifers, as long as he does a decent job doesn't jack up the price doesn't the leads don't fall
completely off. He does a decent job, those clients are going to be with him. And that's exactly what
I'm talking about. So anyway, that's, that's, that is completely normal to happen there. And the
reason why you felt it so much is because you weren't taking enough action that you were
replacing clients as you were losing them. And again, we're not trying to discourage you and
say you're going to lose all of your clients. Absolutely not. If you guys go and pick good
clients, you shouldn't lose any of them. And if you take the time, but what ends up happening,
as Porter said, is as you're trying to get the next deal, you let off the gas a little bit on
this one, if they're not making money, then you risk losing them. Okay, it's just part of the game,
you got to expect it. How did you manage and how do you manage clients with, you know, when you're
in your busy season, and I'm speaking because I know a lot of people on here have other businesses,
other jobs, other responsibilities, and maybe times of the year, they get very busy.
How have you learned to manage your clients during your busy season, which is basically from
March to October?
Yeah, I think the contact with them is huge. I think at least once a month, I feel like the first
six months are the hardest. After you get past six months, you usually can
stop communicating quite as much. I still check in and make sure that they're getting the calls
they need and saying, hey, can you send me pictures, try and update the pictures, you know,
trying to do things. But I mean, in reality, it's just like, hey, are you closing jobs?
How many of these jobs have you closed? How booked out are you? Because if they're busy,
they're going to be fine, right? It's like when they don't have work, when they don't have stuff
that they can do, that's when they get all weird about paying you. But when they're booked out
three or four months, dude, they don't care that they're just trying to keep up. So I think the
contact is huge. But I really don't think that's even as big as just making sure, hey, are you
closing jobs? If you're not, what's the problem? And is it the leads? Because most of the time,
it isn't. Most of the time, it's something they're doing. Maybe it's the way they're
answering the phone, how fast they're calling the lead back. And I kind of try to help them
examine where that they've gone wrong. Phil felt found with another business owner. And then,
you know, I help them with that. And I've usually, I mean, other than if they're really bad business
owners, or, you know, I really have not had issues with losing clients like I did that first year.
Yeah. And that's another thing, guys, when you when you start touching in with touching base
to your clients, make sure that especially during that first six month window, that you're really
taking the time like that's going to be the most hands on you're ever going to be if you can get
them past the first six months, and re sign them into another year. Your your your chances of losing
them is going to be a lot less, it's going to go way down. So during the first few months,
make sure you're checking in monthly at the minimum by monthly would be better and weekly
would be amazing. And what I usually like to do is I like to check in, hey, here's how many leads
you got. And you'd be surprised how many business owners go, I didn't get that many leads. And you're
like, yeah, you did. And you should like, let's get on a zoom here, you know, whatever. And you
start going through it. And you sent them 20 leads, but they only answered 15. You just lost
five right off the top because they don't know the answer. Right. Just go to their phone. Then
of the 15 that they answered, they only booked calls with 12 because they don't know how to book
because the you know, instead of saying, hey, we're a bit out, but we'll put you on a cancellation
list. They're just like, hey, just so you know, we're 12 weeks booked out. And they completely
discouraged that they don't know how to talk to these people. And then of the 12 they book,
they have two that cancel before they come because they don't have any touches in between.
And then of the 10 that they they get to the house, they give estimates to all 10. And they
only follow up with none of them. And they end up closing, you know, so you start realizing and you
can kind of start getting into the weeds with these guys and seeing where they're going wrong.
But guys, you got to remember if you guys have read the E-Myth where it talks about most people
that start a business, especially in the trades, in the home services, these guys worked for
another crew. They either got mad at their boss or they were decent at their job. And they're
like, I'm going to go start my own crew. That does not qualify them to be business owners.
Most of these guys, even if they're really good at what they do, they do not know how to
how to run a business. Some of the best craftsmen are the worst business owners because they just
don't know what they're doing. They're just they're just good at doing the thing. They're
not good at business. OK, so anyway, without getting off in the weeds, make sure that these
people are making money. That's the lesson and the takeaway that I'm taking from this.
OK, Porter, if you were starting today, took everything away, all your clients,
you just had your knowledge. You couldn't reach out to any of your existing clients or old clients.
How long do you realistically think it would take you to go from zero to 10K per month if
you started today? Really, like if I did if I did nothing but this, I bet three months I could get
three months. I get to 10K like that's two clients a month. Like I could easily do that.
I've been in a couple of months. I could do that. Yeah, that's two fifteen hundred ish.
That'd be a that'd be a stretch, but it's doable. I'll tell you guys this.
When in 2020 now, this wasn't just me, by the way, this was me. Francesca was managing most of the
sites. I had somebody that was when the leads would come in, I had somebody that was helping
me call and hook the business owners and I had somebody answering the leads and transferring
the leads. And all I would do was once the business owner was hooked and we found that
they were interested, I would come in, I would talk to the business owner and then I would close
the deal. So we had like a four man team in April, about mid April, like April 15th to May 15th. I
think if I'm if memory serves me correct in 2020, I set a goal with my team. I said I want to do
something crazy. I said I would like to add and I would like to add ten thousand dollars in new
revenue in one thirty day period. Ten thousand dollars of brand new revenue, no SEO, no paper
lead deals, only flat fee deals, new clients. And with that tiny little team, we did it. We hit it.
We took team golfing, had a good time. Interestingly enough, that's April, right?
Three months prior, four months prior, my total revenue was eight to ten thousand dollars a month,
most of that being made up by SEO and one flat fee client. So you can do a lot now.
Fast forward to 2021, August of 2021, in a single month, we added twenty four thousand dollars
of new deals, new monthly recurring revenue in a single month. OK, so three months is completely
doable. I think you could do three. I think anyone on this call, if you were actually doing work and
with singular focus and you were actually just focused on getting deals,
I think you could do that in three months. I do. Now, I think if you just started, I think that
might be a little bit very aggressive. I think for those of you that just started, I think you
get your first deal in three months, but you got to get the first one and you got to get the second
one in Porter. Once you get the first one, is it just me or is the second one come way easier?
Way easier. Well, it's just like a mindset thing. It's so funny. It's just like it just clicks.
It's like you can do it now. And as much as you've watched Porter talk about it,
as much as you've watched me, as much as you've watched Kyle or Jason or Ryan Dalton or whoever,
it's always like, yeah, but my situation is different. And it's not OK. Porter's got a kid.
I've got kids. Porter's got taken over the family farm. He also does stuff at his church he goes to,
which means he's got other responsibilities. He's got in-laws that he has to entertain
and he has to keep. I mean, he's got stuff just like everybody else does. So
don't think that you're special. Porter, what's one thing that you did right that you would do
again? If you started again today, what's one thing that you did right that you would do again?
That's a good question.
And if you want, my next question is what's one thing you did wrong that you would do differently?
And if that one's easier to answer, we can start with that one.
One thing I did wrong was... That one's always easier to answer.
That one's always easier to answer. I think a lot of it was my due diligence too. I think
picking... There's been times where I've just picked the wrong city because I was so like,
I wanted to get a deal so fast that I would say, okay, I got like 10 cities narrowed it down to
five and then I got like two that are like neck and neck and I really didn't know. And it wasn't
like a really like a yes. It didn't really scream yes, but it was still good. And I felt like I
should have just waited. I should have just really done my... Taken my time, got my due diligence
right because it saves you so much time on the back end when it comes to ranking and whatnot.
And it also helps you with finding clients. It's so much easier to find clients when it's
low-hanging fruit. But I will say you'll get caught in analysis paralysis if you're not careful,
so you can't just do due diligence for months and months. But at the same time, I was spending a day
on sometimes looking at cities and I'd make a decision in a day and I should have spent two
or three days going in and making sure that this was a good area. So I would say I definitely got
impatient and I was skipping steps within the course. And if I would have taken that time to
do it, I would have been better off. For example, another thing I did wrong, there have been times
where I've wanted to deal so bad that I thought that going into Facebook and going down in the
Google Maps section to hook business owners was going to be faster than actually creating a list.
And it is so far wrong. I would call business owners and I would get them on a Zoom call
and they wouldn't have money. And I was like, why are they they don't have money? But they
weren't running Google Ads. They weren't doing what you said in the course. But I thought that
I knew better that I could go there faster. And I didn't. And so I went back to the basics. Every
time I do exactly the process that's laid out, it always ends in a deal. And then I'm like, oh,
that's it. And then I get another deal and then I start doing something stupid. And then I lose
four deals. You know, like it's just like you got to stick to what works and stop trying to reinvent
the wheel. Yeah, it's that that, you know, the thing in sales, kiss, keep it stupid, simple,
or keep it simple, stupid. It's that whole thing, guys, I promise you. Everybody does this. You
thought that look, I've created a process. And by the way, this wasn't just it just didn't just come
to my mind from nowhere. I created a process from watching thousands of hours of content,
from buying twenty three thousand dollars in courses, from talking to people, paying mentors.
And over the period, a period of three, four or five years, let's say I started in 2016,
I launched this program in 2020 and 2021. So six years, I developed this process that is very
simple and it works. And if you guys just follow it, it will get you a deal. And at the end of the
deal, you can just start at the beginning and do it again. But everybody does that. They get smart.
They get they, you know, I'm going to I'm going to do this. I'm going to do that.
And the reality is, is there's a reason why this process works. There's a reason why you get why I
was able to use it to scale to six figures a month. There's a reason why it's worked for
hundreds of other people. It's a reason why Ryan Dalton's at eighty seven thousand a month using
the same process in two years. Just go back to the basics. I know that's such a such a boring
advice. You know, I always heard everyone talk about John Wooden, how every year he would
teach his players how to put on their socks correctly, because if they didn't do that,
then they would get blisters and that would affect every part of their game.
And then he would talk about the basketball. You talk about the lines and you talk about
the chess pass and the bounce pass. It sounds really dumb, but the fundamentals are what win
games. And so I think a lot of us have gotten away from the fundamentals, which is go into a
boring niche, go into a city based on the due diligence process that we teach you in the
training. And if it doesn't match exactly, don't go into it. And I know it gets frustrating because,
oh, I got to go look at another city, guys. If you're worried about the time it takes to do
due diligence, go use the ranking engine tool. It speeds it up a lot more. OK, but don't be afraid
to look at a hundred cities to find the one good city, because if you do that, that one city is
going to be a moneymaker and you're going to be able to rank it quickly. You're going to make a
ton of money on it and it's going to be worth way better than what Porter's done. And I've also
done where you just jump into a city and niche and it ends up being the wrong way. Guys, when we
started back in 16, I brought Kyle on back in 2018. He used to go, we had no sales process.
Basically, our meeting would be like, hey, all right, guys, go get some business owners. And
literally Kyle was just going to Google and just like typing in, you know, foundation repair,
Minneapolis, not even thinking about the state, not even thinking about, oh, I wonder if this guy,
just calling people. He ended up selling this deal, guys. He got this guy, shout out to Kyle.
He got this guy to buy 50 websites from us that we own. Great deal. It actually saved us from
basically going under because we were not very cash rich at that time. And I will tell you that
we just went and built, we went and built 50 sites. And I can tell you, not with 100% certainty,
but I would say 95% certainty that of those 50, I don't think we have a single one of those websites
that we still have existing on the interwebs. I think we got rid of all of them. We got rid
of the domains. None of them were built in cities where we were ever going to rank because it was
in the wrong niche. We got away from the basics, right? The only thing that got me to a hundred
thousand a month was going back to the basics, focusing on one thing, just like we talked about
last week, guys, eliminating everything else, simplifying my life, just working, not worrying
about the boys trips, not worried about the pickleball, not worried about the golf, not
worried about the Netflix freaking Tiger King and this, that, and the rest, unless it's the weekends
and just working. And that's how I made, that's how I completely changed my life. Okay.
Porter, we got a question for Joshua Archer. He says, Hey Porter, what was helpful as you worked
through the content? Did you watch and take a lot of notes, watch everything all the way through,
then repeat, watch one video, then act on it? Porter, how did you do it? And then I'll tell people
how I would recommend them doing it. Yeah, I can't watch the whole thing at once and then like wrap
my head around it. So like I'd watch a video and then I would do what it said. So like Nick said,
you know, pick a city. That's what I would do. I'd focus on the city and then I would focus on the
due diligence part of it. And then like the list part and then with content, like I guess,
I guess this is just in general, right? The content of the course. He's talking about going
through the course. Yeah. Yeah. So I would, I would just do exactly how fast Nick does it. So like
just watch the topic, do the work, do, do, do like a couple of modules, do the work and just do it
side by side. Just that worked for me. Cause that way it wasn't like overwhelming and I was able to
like see it from A to Z. Yeah. I recommend the same thing. Go through it guys. If I say to do
something in it, this is not because I'm trying to run a dictatorship here, but if I say to do
something, stop the video, do it. Right. If I says, Hey, go watch this video. Go now go. Here's the
due diligence. Now go pick your city in your niche. Do not go to building your list until you found
your city niche. And you guys might be stuck on build, you know, your city and niche for two weeks.
I hope it doesn't take you that long. Hopefully you can do it in a few days, but you might be.
And I don't even want you to move on until then. I don't want you watching the SEO. I don't want
you watching part two, how to build a website. What a lot of people do, dude, is they get into this
and watching the content makes them feel like they're doing something. Right. So they get
through the first part and it's like, Oh, now you gotta, you gotta pick a city in a niche.
It's like, well, let me watch how to build a list and then how to call the business owner.
And it's like, no, just do it as you go through it. And then by the time you've watched the
training, you've got a deal. Right. You do not need, by the way, if any of you guys are watching
this, you don't have a deal. You should not even be touching section two of the content.
It is not valuable for you to know how to rank a website unless you have a client.
Right. Oh, but I need to be able to talk the lingo and talk about that. Yeah, I get that. But guys,
you can go get a client without knowing how to do that. Trust me. Okay. If you don't have money
coming in, you got a hobby, not a business. Okay. Two more questions I want to ask you,
Porter. Now that you're at 10 K, what does your average day look like?
So I always try to, I always look at my phone to make sure that my Stripe account goes through.
So I always make sure that the payments, the clients that I do have are still paying.
I think I've learned now, something that I'm doing now is I'm trying to be more on top of it,
like having something ready to go next time. What I was doing before was I'd have a site or I'd have
a city and I wouldn't look for any new cities until that one was closed. But then I was always
a month or a couple of weeks behind because I didn't have anything ready to go. So I think
being prepared, that's something that I would do, like focus on and something I would do better
the next time around is be a little bit more prepared. But an average day, wake up,
make sure my Stripe account goes through, make sure the leads are coming through, whatever.
And then I'm just trying to find new cities because I don't have a team. So a lot of it's
doing it myself. So I'm trying to have cities that I can do, doing the boring stuff when the
calling is not available. And then during the day when the business owners are out and about or at
nights, I'll try to call them. But I try to do the boring stuff when you shouldn't be calling
anybody. But the prime calling time, make sure you save that for like hooking business owners
and trying to close deals. Yeah, I like that. And I would say the prime time should be the time you
have the best energy. When you haven't exhausted, like you don't need to go spend your best hours
right when you wake up and your brain's really fresh to go build a website, right? Spend that
when you're just ate lunch and you feel like you should take a nap. Okay. All right. Last
question for reporter is where are you going to be at by the end of 2025? And if you don't hit it,
we are going to slash your tires, something like that. So where are you going to be at, bud?
I want to be, I want to be at $25,000. I set a goal at the beginning of this year to,
well, it was part of last year, but I set goals like before the year ended, but it's kind of
rolling into this year, but I want to be at $25,000. So another 15K by the end of the year.
And I think about it because I was like, man, with farming, is that possible? But
even if I go to slow rate, even if I could just have something in the works every single month,
there are still times where I could close deals. And if I have a process set in place where I can
still be able to rank these out and have a team, then I don't think that's too far fetched. But
I want to be at 25 by the end of the year. Totally doable, bro. Because if you can go to
10K in three months from zero, then you should be able to hit another 15K and retain your 10K
and beat up to 25K. So we're going to hold you to that. There are a couple more questions,
but Porter, if you don't mind, if you don't mind, once we get off to go and just comment
and answer those questions on a comment, I think that'd be great. Like Shiju has one.
He asked about search volume. I will tell you, we just did a live on search volume. If you're
using RankinRent, the RankinRent engine, which I think we ended up saying to be very, very safe.
If the tool says 70 searches per month, on the main keywords, with a lower than $5 CPC, you're
safe to go. If the niche is moderately competitive, if it's very, very low hanging fruit,
you could probably get away with 50 searches. But nonetheless, guys, go watch that live. That was
back when Ryan and I did this. I was in Dubai. I think that was when, anyway, we called it the
magic number, the golden number on search volume or something like that. So anyway, Porter, thanks
for jumping on. Appreciate you guys being on, guys. Let's go. Remember, it's January. People
are spending money again. They're excited. They want to clean up their yard. They want to have
that fresh year. They've got goals just like you. Go hit up all your business owners. Let's go ahead
and see if I got a message back from my boy. If not, then I'm going to hit the next one up.
Let's just go ahead and see. I'm going to use that line you just did.
Tell me to eat sand at any point. Oh, dog. Here it is.
Here it is, bud. I'm going to show it to you so you guys don't know I'm not lying.
I don't want to show you the number, but how do I do this? Anyway, he just said right here, he said
it's today at 2.35, which was 25 minutes ago. He said, let's do it. Just got to set up a time.
Boom, dude. He was paying us I think $2,000 a month when we were doing this. This is for my agency,
guys, of course. This isn't for new students. Again, let me go ahead and read that for you
because I do think it was quite nice if you guys want to use that line. I was going to use
something a little more vulgar, but I didn't. I said, feel free to tell me to go eat sand at
any point, but would love to hop on a Zoom or phone call and see how we can work together.
Look forward to hearing from you soon. Just so you guys know, the week before Christmas,
I hit him up with a message. It said, hey, let's jump on a call, see if we can work together.
It's radio silence. Messaged him on Christmas, wished him Merry Christmas or New Year's.
He responded Merry Christmas or New Year's whatever day it was, but didn't say a word
about my previous text. Hit him today now that it's January. $2,000 bills floating through the
ether. Guys, go ahead if you're a business owner or supporter, thanks for dropping on the call.
See you guys next week. Bye.